one of the favorite things about being
comic-con that we always do what was
that noise oh that's just my therapy
Wilkie Conan your therapy Wookiee yes I
get nervous around large crowds and I
wanted to see your show so he's helping
me with my anxiety okay
look sir therapy animals are course or
allowed in the theatre but I'm afraid it
can't be a Wookiee some people are very
allergic to them like I'm guessing that
guy next to you I'm just it's a guess
it's pretty bad my throat's closing yeah
take a claritin okay you're a Comic Con
you didn't think you'd see a Wookiee
that's on you okay doctor please please
the bigger issue is that last year
someone in our audience brought a
service wookie the wookie got upset
remember this Andy well he got upset and
it tore off an usher zarm
yeah isn't that right Charles yes sir
last year yeah I'm sorry but your wookie
is gonna have to leave now wait a second
are you gonna tell my wookie after we
travelled all the way from Baltimore to
see this show that he's not gonna see
the cast and creator of Breaking Bad
he loves Breaking Bad I'm sorry my hands
are tied Charles can you take care of
this if you don't mind it yes I'm sorry
sir
you're gonna you'll have to come with me
at least IMAX
[Music]
it's great our how realistic I don't
think we heard your last line it was
really great
hey would you like to hear it again :
why not well at least now I match
you
you